only you have the power to change you
let's do this thing
today you will eat clean healthy foods
after school drop off you will go
directly to ballet class
i will have a nice day babe the coffee
only
clean healthy food drink famous
cheeseburgers three large fries and a
chocolate shake thanks
after school drop-off i will go to
ballet class
it's closed i will have a nice day
professor reuben is getting fired
we're gonna need money i love you
whatever happens you think something bad
will happen
no you're trusting this ding dong with
your life
hello stop it
what's up lady sorry
you ready to do this thing now you've
done it she sees what mess you are
actually i feel better than i have been
in a long time where are you going
i've been doing aerobics classes you
should check it you might like it
and after just one class you can feel it
happening you becoming you again
how long can we afford to live off our
savings we're all going to do our part
and by we he needs you you ever think of
hiring another teacher
if you screw this up you're done here
it's kinky bottle blonde to the right
oh sorry i meant you're left i can't
keep up
blend in i feel like that constantly
i can come to your house i could teach
you aerobics there
there's a small chance it might not be a
lame business idea
you don't know what i'm capable of i
built something
something solid that's all yours what
the hell is all this
no one is taking it away
don't underestimate me
go get him tiger
you